واحده من الاشياء التي كانت ملفته للنظر
في تقريركم الحقيقه الحديث عن التطرف
والعنف ذكرتم في التقرير ان الاسباب ربما
ربما او الدوافع لا تعود لاسباب دينيه
انما تعود لاسباب اقتصاديه بالدرجه الاولى
خاصه في
افريقيا وجنوب الصحراء كيف تفسر لنا هذا
ما هي مقاربتكم
هذا الحوار بسؤالك حول كيف يمكن منع
النزاعات ومن الدروس التي تعلمناها انه في
دول مثل جنوب الصحراء التي اصبح فيها
التطرف احد ابرز عوامل عدم الاستقرار في
الساحل ولكن ايضا في اجزاء من موزمبيق وفي
غرب افريقيا هناك ظاهره تبدو فيها مجموعه
تعتقد في التطرف العنيف بصدد التسلل في
عده دول ونعرف مبدئيا ان مشاكلها مثل
الفقر وعدم المساواه وعدم قدره المؤسسات
الحكوميه على العمل انتجت فراغان سمح لهذه
المجموعات بان تجد موتها قدم لها بل وان
تجند عده اشخاص ونحاول ربط العلاقه بين كل
هذا ففي عام 2017 نشرنا استطلاعنا الاول
حول مقاتلين سابقين تم تجنيدهم من قبل
مجموعات متطرفه وقد وسعنا هذا العمل الان
ونشرنا التقدير الثاني بعد ان قابلنا فيه
اكثر من 2000 شاب تم تجنيدهم في ثمان دول
على امتداد منطقتي الساحل والقرن
الافريقيين وطرحنا عليهم سؤالا حول ما
الذي دفعهم الى الانضمام الى هذه الجماعات
هناك كانت هناك خلاصات مهمه جدا الكثير من
الناس كانوا يعتقدون ان الرساله الدينيه
كانت عنصر الجذب الاول عند الانضمام الى
هذه الجماعات لكن في الواقع عندما تتحدث
للناس صغار السن فان العامل الاقتصادي
والوضع الاجتماعي هما العاملان الاهم مثل
البطاله وعدم توفر متطلبات الحياه او الفق
هذا هو الدافع الاول وليس الدين في
الحقيقه ما يمثل المشجع الاول ثانيا عرفنا
ان التعليم ايضا عامل مهم فعندما تستثمر
في التعليم فانك على الاقل ستنقذ ثلاثه
عشر بالمئه من هؤلاء المجندين وثالثا اشار
الكثير منهم الى حوادث قادحه كانوا على
علاقه بها ادت بهم الى الالتحاق بهذه
الجماعات مع ضلوع قوات الامن والجيش في
التعامل مع تلك الحوادث التي تسجل فيها
انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان ترى فيها والدك
مثلا يعتقل او شقيقك يصاب او يعتقل دون
اذن قضائي لكن هناك ايضا غادروا هذه
الجماعات او رغب بذلك لاسباب مختلفه
يعودون اليها لان وعودا قدمت اليهم لم
تتحقق لذلك فقد اتاحت لنا هذه المقابلات
التعرف على اسباب انضمام هؤلاء الصغار الى
هذه الجماعات وايضا ما يمكن القيام به منع
ذلك لان تداعيتي هذا على بعض الدول تعد
كارثيه انظري الى مالي او بوركينا فاسو
فقبل عشر او خمسه عشره سنه كانت الظروف
مهيئه لهما للبدء في طريق الازدهار والان
هما تعانيان من اجل الحفاظ على القدره على
اداء الوظائف الاساسيه المنوطه بالدول هل
تعتقد بان التنميه قد تكون بديل عن التسلح
او عن الاسلحه
نحن بصدد تعلم كيفيه التعامل مع هذه
الظاهره اولا عبر توطيد عوامل الاستقرار
مثلما فعلنا في العراق لان في منطقه
الساحل ينبغي البدء بالتجمعات المحليه
بدءا من العمد فرؤساء مجالس المحليه
فالمحافظين والسلطات المحليه يحاول ان
نعيد لهذه التجمعات الاسباب التي تجعلها
مقتنعه بصواب الاستمرار داخل الدول عبر
توفير سوق او مركز امن وبنيه للتعليم
والصحه يجعلك تستعد ثقه الناس وايمانهم
بقدرتهم على اعاده بناء تجمعاتهم بما يضع
حجر الاساس لدوله تعمل من جديد وتوفر
الامل لمواطنيها وتمنعهم من الابتعاد عنها
بسبب عدم وجود مركز الشرطه او نظاما
للقضاء ما يستدعي الجماعات المتطرفه
للقدوم لتوفر لهم حسب عقيدتها ادارات
محليه من ضمنها الحفاظ على الامن والقضاء
بين الناس وفقا لمعاييرها لذلك اعتقد اننا
تعلمنا عده دروس على مدى السنوات الاخيره
ابرزها ضروره اعاده بناء المؤسسات واقامه
انظمه القضاء والامن وتوفير الفرص
الاقتصاديه لذلك نعمل مع السلطات المحليه
وخاصه الزعماء المحليين وقاده التجمعات
لانهم هم من يعرفون حاجاتها وبجزء بسيط من
الاموال صدقا التي تنفق على مهمات حفظ
السلام والامن يمكنك اعاده خلق فرص
التنميه وهذا هو السبيل لقطع الطريق امام
التطرف العنيف من جهه وايضا اعاده الامل
للناس باستعاده الثقه في مستقبل دولهم
مجددا